cock-block very famous city everyone
knows about it it's like rome cairo
dashboard we found Tosh Pollock in 2011
and I want to show it to you here what
you're looking at here is an animation
of ground-penetrating radar
we've only excavated a very small part
of the city so far yeah we understand
exactly how big it is where the walls
are and how its laid out simply on the
basis or using a radar signal fired into
the ground that bounces back anomalies
and gives us a very accurate map of what
is going on under the surface so you
might say well okay so why do we how
does this relate alright so you found a
city along the Silk Road probably to
another Silk Road city we know about
Silk Road cities 75% of them all on the
Silk Road we got it
well this one is unique or amongst the
unique sites we know of because it
belonged to a time period when the Silk
Road was controlled by the largest
nomadic Empire before the Mongols the
car accounted huh Nate this was a
company this was an aggregate of tribal
communities of nomads that decided they
were tired of having to fight against
everybody else so they got together and
created a polity and that policy had
some pretty amazing consequences first
and foremost they became not only the
traders of but the purveyors of
high-carbon steel now high carbon steel
is significant because it gives us all
the buildings in San Francisco it gives
us cars it gives us samurai swords it
gives us basically arms and when you're
in a world in which swords and
battle-axes are your number one arms
having a sword that's a lot better than
a piece of of crap of casted iron is
really important important enough that
the Arab armies of the Caliphate in the
near east purchased their swords from
Central Asia and no swords became the
very swords that deflected the first
Crusaders and won the first crusade for
the Arab armies high carbon steel has
never been unimportant from the day it
was invented until now that economic
drive also inspired them to start to
participate participate in notions of
civilization that could in fact be seen
as exterior to their nomadic origins
they hired Persian architects and
worked with local developers to make
Mozilla and Craig's and some of them are
quite incredible these are standing
Mozilla it from the attend century they
had poets cartographers polymaths
astronomers these are not folks who were
barbaric Outsiders but in fact at this
stage in their career development were
beginning to assimilate to a broader
civiles model of civilization this
cities an important lesson for us -
block did grow up pretty fast but it
only lasted 200 years and I think it was
the hubris of the carrot owners they
were known a nomadic polity they started
to compete with empires they started to
build cities and settle down and dive
into that old model of civilization and
I think it was their downfall I think
they went too far I think that they
stopped being sustainable so they were
too rigid too stable to assimilative if
you will
now I'm not fighting against
assimilation but I'm fighting against is
the idea here that this nomadic system
which had functioned for already 2,000
or more 3,000 years this connectivity
and network and it's open ecumene
started to lock up and the continents in
the sense played a role in that and
their networks froze and their cities
died